alain rousselot payet comment on fait
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique quand on est maire d'une
commune ou qu'il avait été déplacée
longtemps que ça oui tout à fait mais
écoutez je crois que c'est en matière de
d'écologie c'est ce que nous disons
souvent il faut pas une écologie
d'incantation il faut une écologie de
solutions est ce que nous proposons est
à l'échelle d'une ville comme celle de
chalon sur saône et pour agir sur
l'écologie il ya trois leviers que nous
proposons la première c'est les
transports publics puisqu'il faut
effectivement incité les chalonnais
apprendre plus les transports publics
ont la vie chalonnaise est également les
grands chalets pour le coup puisque
c'est eux aussi qu'ils viennent sur la
ville ça c'est une première mesure et on
a des mesures concrètes qu'on n'a pas
trop parlé de mesures concrètes ce sens
c'est un petit peu dommage le temps nous
presse effectivement voilà la deuxième
chose toujours dans les transports c'est
la mobilité douce
ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure il ya un
vrai plan vélo la ville possède
aujourd'hui une grande discontinuité au
niveau de ces pistes cyclables et même
si elle c'était une compétence
effectivement du grand chalon mais là
c'est encore une fois de plus à la ville
d'impulser cela au centre-ville et ont
son sein et le troisième élément par
rapport à ce que disait monsieur là
ouais c'est effectivement la
visualisation je pense que les à la
ville de futurs en tout cas les deux
futurs c'est celle qui ont une ses
capacités à revitaliser leur place à
créer ce qu'on appelle même ou en termes
de propositions des forêts urbaines et
je pense notamment à l'avenue niépce qui
est une à une une avenue relativement
important qui peut être l'épiné dorsale
de cette revitalisation top oui moi je
souscris tout à fait il faut carrément
essayer de créer un corridor vert il
faut il faut vraiment passer à quelque
chose de 2,2 d'ambitieux parce que c'est
quand même d'autres à venir sur les
vingt trente quarante cinquante
prochaines années
si aujourd'hui une ville ne ne se dote
pas aujourd'hui d'un vrai plan d'action
sur sur l'environnement je pense qu'elle
va elle va droit dans le mur faut dire
ce qui est donc ça passe au niveau de
l'énergie
ça passe au niveau de la végétalisation
ça passe aussi au niveau juste de 2,1
entre parenthèses la rééducation un peu
des moeurs est d aider des gens je pense
qu'il faut si on passait par là et là où
vous vous posiez la question tout à fait
tout à leur pardon monsieur
à ma droite c'est très important d'en
passer justement par la mairie pour
qu'il y ait une transition de ceux de
cette impulsion la au sein de tout de
tout l'est de tous les habitants que
tout le monde se sente à se sentent
intégrés dans la une revisite justement
du verre et des jeux des choses des
choses de la biodiversité déjà oui c'est
la responsabilité du maire et de
l'agglomération puisque la compétence
est partagé entre la ville et
l'agglomération sur ce sujet là bien sûr
tout seul on ne peut que contribuer mais
on peut tout de même contribué
la question a été cité de l'avenue
niépce
il ya trois ans qu'on travaille sur ce
dossier avec un conseil citoyen qui a
vraiment bien travaillé sur ce sujet là
l'idée c'est de l'art qualifier c'est un
gros investissement assez de l'ordre de
plus de 6 millions d'euros l'estimation
en recentrant la circulation automobile
est vraiment en retraitant les
esplanades avec beaucoup plus de vert
nous voulons aussi c'est inscrit dans le
programme végétalisée l'esplanade de
l'espace des arts créer un jardin
temporaire en période estivale sur la
place de deux villes on veut pas casser
les équipements qui a été fait c'est
aussi l'argent du contribuable mais par
contre créé un jardin temporaire créer
trois nouveaux jardins en centre-ville
notamment un dans le parc de la banque
de france que la ville est en train
d'acheter je vais doit signer le
compromis dans quelques jours et puis et
puis le programme a commencé en plus
pendant ces vacances végétaliser les
cours d'école parce que on se rend
compte que en fin de période scolaire
c'est assez dur
donc on est en train de créer vraiment
il fait part que à l'intérieur même des
cours 10